yeah welcome to this video I'm playing
against I'm a german player German flag
uncle yo doc and and this is
unbelievable this guy has got the very
high rating 25 something at his plate
2705 minute games and I never played him
I'm absolutely sure to never have seen
this handle okay this is interesting I
never ever never ever played him and I
played my fair share of five-minute
games and my time okay he's playing the
fire rockets gambit this is yeah yeah
well I hope I don't hand some people who
actually like this opening i think it's
it's something you're simply bad but
okay i'm not an expert and this is the
big thing quite often people who play
that um really no lines and have the
ideas and if you um if you face them you
often only know okay it is not great you
know one or two move send and then you
on your own i think this is this is this
is all right like no needs to play a d5
this is what I know but not much more
yeah this is just losing because of 93
how has has this guy 2500 strange
Nigeria c4 and this is basically over
but ok it's not you need to still be a
little bit precise because the night is
on h1 it is lost but it's so what
yeah okay you can can do that it's not
much of a difference so the problem is
that this night is so going to get get
lost how to learn how to play this now
most precisely takes should I take on
the six probably not Bishop g5 is also
not not bad at all
yeah basically you can pick it up
whenever you want yeah Bishop g5 I think
he needs to go Bishop e7 now let's not
i'm not much else this was my idea takes
takes with the with the night if he
takes on d6 I've got drooped you one or
long castles cannot cancel short because
of Knight f6 yeah all this move do I
have some direct some direct way to play
takes on g6 yeah but there's no no big
follow up okay
hm
yeah well so bit shocking all those all
these moves but maybe it is relatively
best
so how to continue a rookie one
d one probably yeah all the things I
just need to get the night and then
everything's fine but it's not not that
easy night to h4 and takes on f5 or
queen it what does he do on Queenie to
probably King to f7 now very ugly but
maybe a what what what else g3 Bishop g2
where this is maybe they're the easiest
way okay come on I need to get the night
look check just King f1 you cannot play
a form because of the Queen unknown on
g6 so just Queen it to the right okay
well that ok he my turn I can go here
also and then he plays a fall
BAM I spent too much time on this
nonsense
yeah it's just a very good end game but
i'm down on one minute or down to one
minute
just got two pieces for for the rook and
the porn but my pieces are not bad at
all good knight on d5
yeah I'm catching up a bit on the clock
this is sad this is helpful
I'm not sure that this was a good idea
going directly into to g5 he didn't play
g5 for whatever reason
it's a matter of time I know what to get
him giving him the edge sport is risky
but I've got this this night now here
this was the idea yeah this was was very
complicated but probably all right I
mean one gave me basically winning
position in the opening but it was still
very tense let's have a have a brief
look here very difficult to say if I've
got something something better
yeah I know no probably yeah it's better
to take on his heaven and then take 1d6
that that's also i'm probably all right
but f5 is really a set amazing
yeah by now I'm not sure I mean it still
looks good but this was strong Queenie
form if I take then he gets to get gets
to f2 like this and something like this
and like wins so this is I cannot take
on e form and now he he needs to return
it and this is a better end game for i
doing not sure if this was the most
precise but it always should be somewhat
better for wide yeah I hear this was of
course on some better a matter of time I
need to move quickly but the computer
always gives me some advantage so it
isn't it doesn't seem like I I spoiled
too much
yeah g4 was just hoping that that this
was good and this is of course very
strange why didn't you play route d7
because this this now certainly a group
tonight c8 was stronger even okay I'm
glad to have found this and with the
little time and night c8 was stronger
but I saw this idea with Bishop c82 to
not get this bishop and at night meet
against possibly I mean it's got the
pawns maybe I didn't even reach this but
Bishop at night made with 20 seconds
that's not possible really yeah very a
somewhat strange game but interesting
game yeah thanks for watching